Ah c'era già una nuova marca Aurelio A
che numero siamo arrivati l'ultima Se
non erro mi risale a due settimane fa
l'hai dimenticata in fretta quella come
sei chiamata Sharon Sharon la
delicatissima Sharon Marco Aurelio Ah
quindi questa te piace per davvero Mmm e
senti ce l'ha almeno diploma qua Senti
non ci gira attorno Marco Aurelio Famme
vede sta foto vai
Toglimi subito questa immagine satanica
andata avanti Marco Ora io mi sto
sentendo male Ma che te devo dì ma gli
altri almeno lo nascondevano meglio
Questa ce l'ha scritto in faccia Marco
Aurelio mi voglio far mettere incinta e
fa la mantenuta a vita Ecco cosa c'è
scritto questa in faccia Cioè ma fammi
capire ma quando uscite insieme no ma di
che cavolo parlate Ah non parlate
Complimenti Marco Aurelio Senti ma che
ti mancano per caso i soldi e allora
pagati le marca Aurelio pagati una
escort ti diverti e poi te ne torni a
casa ognuno c'ha la vita sua Io
preferirei che fossi gay preferirei che
tu mi portassi a casa degli uomini
piuttosto che ste sciacquette de merda
Bravo Vattene vattene da lei fatti
rigirare come un Pedalino Marco Aurelio
io ti avviso e se al pranzo di Natale me
porti sta Ragazzi io ti blocco tutti i
conti Eh e la volta buona che fa venire
un infarto a tuo padre vedi che devi fa